as morbid as it sounds
nobody knows when they're gonna die I'm
[ __ ] I find that a little terrifying
and just want to shove my life full of
experiences before it's too late so I'm
gonna get as much of my bucket list done
as I can
in one week something new every day
[Music]
[Applause]
I only have one week so no big traveling
marriage and kids not gonna do that this
week go to outer space is just not super
realistic right now so that's gone after
taking everything into account I'm left
with six items learn to skateboard write
a children's novel get a tattoo tell my
parents how much I love them
skydive and play with a monkey all right
[Applause]
today I'm learning to skateboard I have
my helmet and elbow pads and I got a
board as well as my friend Steven who's
gonna teach me
I really hope Megan Falls my main goal
for today is to skateboard from here at
work to the ArcLight
which is where I parked sometimes bucket
list number one let's go I can do this
okay that's something to start with
[Music]
yeah I think we can move on I'm gonna go
out front hit some curbs can we say
another word other than hit Oh am I so
nervous
what's that thing skirt no : a the thing
in the road this is a leaf okay
hey other excuses nope pretty sick
skater girls am i fast I did it guys
it's over by some trash yep that's good
I can't stand to the ArcLight constantly
going he Pope will be so concerned we'll
just do it like one surprise more I
can't imagine why I'd need more than
that
I'm feeling very discouraged this is
just way more challenging than I thought
it would be I can hardly stand on the
freaking board okay let's go
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I'm exhausted I feel like some people
watch this video just be like big but I
was scared this is like what I was most
afraid to do and I did it day one is
done let's go write a children's book
tomorrow I've always wanted to write a
children's novels so I could like give
back to kids what I got out of these
books I guess I've never gone through
with this because I just didn't think I
was creative enough if I die and I
haven't written a children's novel
that's one more thing that I would
regret not having done I think I want it
to be about mental health like a lot of
adults still don't understand certain
aspects of mental health so I figure
let's start him young talking about
depression I'm not kidding this book is
about depression but it's gonna be great
[Music]
oh I titled my book read a rabbit and
the invisible injury I don't have a ton
of children that I can share my story
with at this moment so I am going to
round up some co-workers and have
storytime read a rabbit foxy Felicia and
trusty the turtle are all best friends
they play every single day read a rabbit
notices she hasn't been happy oh I
forgot to tell you this is about
depression
foxy Felicia and trusty the turtle stop
by Rita the rabbit's house but she shoes
them away foxy and trusty get tired of
reader rabbit not joining them one day
Rita the rabbit finds a piece of paper
on the ground it's an invitation to a
party foxy and trusty are throwing and
Rita is not invited Rita goes to see
doctor dolphin with her mom she hasn't
been eating or sleeping the doctor
explains that Rita has depression an
invisible injury that hurts the brain
doctor dolphin explains that even though
you can't see the broken parts on the
outside the hurt that depression causes
to your insides can be just as painful
and difficult to heal Felicia and trusty
ask how they can help
Rita asks for patience and understanding
and for the friends to know that
depression is an injury Rita might be
working on for a long time with a deeper
understanding their friendship
flourishes BND's okay day two is over
this is gonna be a real book shortly
link below - bye
tomorrow I get a tattoo have you thought
a lot about the pain
I'm so excited but I also feel very ill
I brought my boyfriend and my best
friend here for moral support I guess
the reason I've never gotten a tattoo is
fear of regretting it later it's fine
lasers no to the chair yeah what are you
gonna get tattooed today I'm actually
getting a piece of advice that my friend
Mallory gave me which is lean and I
remember her sitting at my kitchen table
as she you know was telling me like I
don't know what to do I just want to
take this big leap into this new
adventure and I told her you just gotta
lean in lean into the fear and do it
even though it scares you okay gonna be
worth it okay there's gonna be a lot of
talking I talk when I'm nervous I also
ask a lot of questions we good no wait
wait good talk okay ready yeah there we
go
one guy are you kidding that's it very
serious yeah that couldn't have been it
do it again oh I'm gonna be addicted
after this it's not nearly as painful as
I thought it was so the baby after this
that's the pain here it is it's perfect
it's exactly what I imagined I'm halfway
done with my bucket list now I have a
whole body ready for more tattoos let's
do day four
I'm at my parents house right now if
they died before I have the chance to
like sit them down and make sure that
they understood how much they mean to me
and how much I loved them I would be
devastated so today we're gonna make
sure that I never have to regret that I
have brought you here to our kitchen
table laughs this part of my bucket list
was to tell you both how much I love you
I know that people have their parents
died they're like I wish I could just
tell them one last time how much I love
them and I never want to have that
regret so I just wanted to see my this
is my death thank you
I didn't write a speech I don't have
anything planned that was kind of it
don't die I don't plan on anytime soon
but we will hold on to this forever and
ever I love you what's the watch
today it's guy diving diving from the
sky up there onto the planet earth I
brought my mom from your mom why did you
insist on coming because of the chances
you take and that you follow your heart
okay going isn't the time for emotional
[ __ ] this is the time to jump from the
sky let's do it
freeze-frame
[Music]
say goodbye to my mom possibly forever
just kidding
[Music]
[Music]
Omega
welcome back down oh my god you leave
the plane and you're just [ __ ]
falling like I've never experienced
anything like that we're like you really
are just like falling the camera guy
kept like grabbing my hand like yeah
smiles like wow I'm still processing it
[Music]
tomorrow's a day that we play with
monkeys oh we're gonna wash them we're
gonna bite for him gonna be so fun it's
day six it's the last day of the bucket
list I can't believe it this is
something that was on the top of my
first bucket list and I can't believe
that I get to make that dream come true
today and I was told they're very
attracted to color and sparkle which is
why I put all this on this could be a
great day let's get down to some monkey
business just gonna put on her little
bathing belt
[Music]
so what you wanna do megan is telling
you love her give her lip smacks that's
love when people smile at a monkey
that's that's aggression no is so
aggressive he is having a grand old time
the one with the funny hairdo squirt
squirt and she's 23 years old all right
make it have a seat normally it takes a
little while for the monkeys to warm up
to you but he's already excited about
all your bling
[Music]
a little bit of monkey politics going on
right now oh this word is telling Marley
not to touch the food my hand a little
baby is this one keeping his hand on me
to say like you're my friend don't be
like she's cleaning you you know his
woman Megan sorry J hey everybody this
is Christy the baboon and Christy is 13
years old
[Music]
best friends forever means Bert it's me
and square forever starting right now
this has been the absolute best way to
cap off my bucket list my five-year-old
self and my 25 year old self are so at
peace what a great week guys and those
are all the words that I can conjure in
this moment this past week has been an
absolute whirlwind I accomplished things
that I only quietly dreamed about for my
whole life and if I've learned anything
it's just that there is no ready there's
no such thing as ready
there's only such a thing as right here
and right now if you're too scared to go
pursue the things that you want to do
with your life what's the point what is
the point of living if you're not gonna
live it the way that you want I was
ecstatic
to cross off every item off that last
bucket list but there's still a million
things that I want to do so I made a new
bucket list
[Music]
hello again what's up man
[Music]